Brown: Joe and I met in 1966
when we began our
internships at the Massachussetts
General Hospital
in Internal Medicine.
I had been a
medical student at the
University of Pennsylvania,
the nation's
oldest medical school,
and Joe had been a...
had graduated from
Southwestern Medical College
in Dallas, Texas,
the nation's youngest
medical school
that I had never heard of.
I thought it was a
Bible school.
But, within two days after
we began our internship,
we realized that we had
something in common.
We were both interested
in the fundamental
basis of disease.
Not only in taking
care of our patients,
which was
our first responsibility,
but also
trying to figure out
why this person
had a heart attack?
Why this person
had rheumatoid arthritis?
Why did this person
have pneumonia?
And it was that interest
in the basis of disease
that created
this friendship that
has now lasted since 1966.
After our residencies
we went to the
National Institutes of Health,
where both of
us worked with very
exceptional scientists.
Joe with Marshall Nirenberg
and I with Earl Stadtman,
two of the best,
most brilliant
scientists at NIH,
but we also had clinical duties,
and there we
saw a patient
that actually determined
the scientific course
of the rest of our lives.
Goldstein: So the patient
that Mike and I saw
at the NIH was a little girl
the first patient,
with a disease called
familial hypercholesterolemia.
Also called
homozygous familial
hypercholesterolemia
or FH. And her brother
actually had
the same disorder,
and this little girl
has a very high cholesterol.
Her cholesterol is as high
as 800 to 900
milligrams per deciliter.
The normal of a
child of this age
would be about a 120
milligrams per deciliter.
And most of this
high cholesterol
was in a
lipoprotein called LDL
which is known
to everyone as the
bad form of cholesterol.
And when LDL
accumulates in the blood
as in this little girl
it deposits in the skin
in these little
yellow lumps you see
on the surface of her skin.
They are called xanthomas.
And it also accumulates
in the artery wall
and produces
coronary heart disease,
and this little girl
had a heart attack
when she was
six years of age.
Now, this little girl
had only elevated LDL.
She had no high
blood pressure.
She had no diabetes.
She didn't smoke.
She didn't have a
Type A personality.
Her only risk factor
for having a heart attack
at age 6
was this high level of LDL.
So this was one of the
best examples of
a disease where we
really know the cause.
And the cause of the disease
in this little girl
is an increased level of her LDL.
And so it will be
important to understand
the basis of why
her LDL is elevated
and also how it
causes her disease.
Brown: This is LDL.
The lipoprotein that builds up
in the plasma of this
young girl.
It's a spherical particle
that's about the size
of a small virus.
And each LDL particle
has 1500 molecules of
cholesterol within its core.
And it's surrounded by
a polar coat of phospholipid
and a protein called ApoB.
And LDL circulates
in the blood
on average for about
three days
in humans
and eventually it leaves
the blood stream.
When we began our work,
no one knew anything
about what controlled
the level of LDL
in the blood.
We were interested
in this disease because
not only do the
homozygotes have problems,
but the heterozygotes,
people who inherit
one copy of the
abnormal gene
have a moderately
elevated cholesterol,
and they have heart attacks
not at age six,
but at age sixty.
And so if you ignore
the homozygotes,
the heterozygotes
transmit their disease
in an autosomal
dominant fashion
through the pedigree.
And so having a single copy
of the mutant gene,
no matter what it is,
produced the disease.
Now at the time,
there were about 35
single gene diseases
that had been worked out
and the defective gene
product was known.
All 35 of those were enzymes.
Mutations in enzymes,
and all of them
were autosomal recessive.
That means that the
heterozygote had no symptoms.
But in the case of
familial hypercholesterolemia
the heterozygote had a disease.
And we thought that
if we could understand this disease
it would be the first
dominant disease
that could be elucidated
in humans,
and it might teach us
something about
proteins that are not enzymes.
We assumed that it
was not going to be an enzyme.
And that it would probably
be some disorder
of regulation.
Now Joe had promised
his professor at
Southwestern Medical
College that he would
return there after his training.
And Joe and I talked about this,
and Joe, and we decided
that I would also go to Dallas.
And we went.
And when we went to Dallas,
we would both try
to figure out what type of defect
could cause this high LDL level.
And the unique approach
that we took was
to study the metabolism
of cholesterol
in cultured cells.
We obtained biopsies
from children with
familial hypercholesterolemia
and compared them
with normal cells
and studied the
regulation of cholesterol
synthesis, because we thought that
this would be some
regulatory abnormality.
So here is an experiment
that Mike and I
carried out in 1973.
And it is arguably,
probably, the most exciting experiment
that we've ever done
and it really hooked us
on science
and also taught us a lesson
that I will come back to
after describing the experiment.
So as Mike prointed out,
we wanted to understand
what there was about
the regulation of cholesterol synthesis
in these children
with homozygous FH
that was different from normal.
And so, at the time
it was known from studies
in rats and mice
that when you fed
one of these small animals cholesterol
you would suppress
cholesterol synthesis
in the liver.
That was a hint that
there was a regulatory system
and that the liver
was known to be the
most important organ
in the body for
controlling cholesterol,
but there was no way
that we could get liver biopsies
from patients.
So we chose fibroblasts
which one could get,
skin fibroblasts, and this was
sort of a heretical
idea at the time
that one would study
a fundamental process
that was going on in the liver
in a fibroblast,
but we did it anyway.
And here's the experiment.
And the first experiment
we did worked,
and it was really quite dramatic.
So what we did was to compare
fibroblasts grown
in fetal calf serum
which contains LDL
from a normal subject
and one of these
children with homozygous
familial hypercholesterolemia.
And you can see in the red curve
on the left that
the level of the
cholesterol synthesis
was very low,
almost undetectable.
Well, now, as a surrogate
for a cholesterol synthesis,
we use the enzyme
HMG CoA reductase
which had been known from
these animal studies
to be a key rate controlling enzyme
in the cholesterol
biosynthetic pathway
so we were able
to set up an assay
for this enzyme
and we would after incubating
the cells with this
fetal calf serum that
contained LDL,
we would make extracts
and do the measurements.
So you can see that
at zero time,
in the red curve,
the level was very low.
And then when we
removed  the serum
and the LDL from the media
for the next 24 hours,
the enzyme activity
of the normal cells
in red went up 50-100 fold.
And then when we
on the right panel
when we removed... added LDL back
you can see that
that very high level
of the enzyme HMG CoA reductase
came down to
the basal level when the LDL
was added back.
So this was a...
this in itself was a
very interesting experiment
in the normal
because it told us that
there was an effective
LDL cholesterol
regulating the activity
of this enzyme
that reflected
the cholesterol biosynthetic pathway
in the normals.
That in itself was exciting,
but the real dramatic result
was when this result
in the normal
was compared
to the FH homozygote
shown in yellow.
And you can see that at zero time
in the presence of
fetal calf serum
and LDL, the level
of the enzyme
HMG CoA reductase
and cholesterol synthesis
was a hundred times
higher than in the normal
and it didn't change
no matter what we did.
When we removed the LDL
it stayed high, and when
we added LDL back
it stayed high.
So this was
really dramatic.
It was really all or none
and that was one of the things
that I think not only
was it an exciting result, but it
sort of addicted us to the
fact that we were really
interested in
all future experiments
and seeing big changes.
We don't usually see
changes of a hundred fold
but at least it told us
that one had to have
a really big change
to really work out something.
Now our simplest interpretation
from this result when Mike and I
sat down and tried to
deal with it after 24 hours of being
off the wall with excitement.
We decided that
the simplest interpretation was
that the FH homozygote
cells had a mutation
in their enzyme
HMG CoA reductase
that rendered the enzyme
resistant to feedback
regulation by cholesterol.
So we said, ok, well, if that is true
then we should be able to
add cholesterol not in LDL
but in ethanol
and we'd get the same result.
But then when we did that
the curve, the yellow curve,
the FH homozygote
came down
from this hundred fold
just like the normal.
And so the normal
and the FH homozygote
cells were now
responding
to the cholesterol in ethanol
whereas the FH homozygote
did not respond to the LDL.
So that then told us that
our original hypothesis
was wrong and now
we have a new hypothesis
that said that the
defect in the
FH homozygote was a
failure to extract
the cholesterol from LDL.
So how does
a normal cell...
This now became the question...
How does a normal cell
extract the cholesterol
from LDL.
Brown: So we radiolabeled
LDL with iodine-125
and incubated it
with the fibroblasts.
And what we saw
was that when we incubated
the LDL with normal fibroblasts
there was high affinity
cell surface binding that was
saturatable as shown by
the red line on this slide.
But when we incubated
the LDL with the
FH homozygote fibroblasts
there was no binding.
So the problem was
that there must have been
a receptor on the cell
surface that binds LDL
and the FH homozygote cells
lacked this receptor.
Now this was 1974.
It was the very, very early days.
Receptors were kind of
theoretical concepts.
How they worked
was.... there was
very little known
about how they actually worked.
But we went one step further
when we incubated
the cells with I-125 LDL.
We followed what
happened to the LDL
after the binding reaction.
And we were shocked to find
that the I-125 LDL
was totally degraded.
The protein was degraded
down to amino acids.
And  the only way that could happen
would be if the LDL had been
taken into the cell
and degraded
in the digestive organelle
of the cell
which is the lysosome.
Goldstein: So once we knew
that there was
a putative receptor
on the surface of the cells
we advanced the concept
of an LDL receptor
pathway in which the LDL bound to
receptors on the cell surface
in specialized regions called
coated pits.
And our colleague and collaborator
Richard Anderson was
able to demonstrate
by electron microscopy
the localization
of ferritin labeled LDL
in these coated pits.
Coated pits are only
about 2% of the cell surface
of a fibroblast
and so it's a very
specialized region
for rapid endocytosis
and internalization
of proteins like LDL.
So once the LDL
bound the coated pit,
the coated pits
pinched off to form coated vesicles
which delivered the LDL
to endosomes
and then ultimately to the lysosomes
where the LDL was degraded
and the cholesterol was released,
and that cholesterol
was then used
by the cell
for membrane synthesis.
So we now knew
from the LDL receptor pathway
that in addition to
obtaining cholesterol
from cholesterol synthesis,
cells could also obtain
cholesterol through the
receptor mediated endocytosis
of LDL, and this cholesterol
not only
was used for the synthesis
of plasma membranes, but also
it exerted the feedback regulation
on the enzymes
involved in the cholesterol
biosynthetic pathway.
And it also exerted a feedback
suppression on the gene
for the LDL receptor
so one had a coordinate
feedback regulatory system
based on both entry from LDL
and the biosynthesis.
So what happened
in the FH homozygote cells
that lacked LDL receptor?
How did they
obtain their cholesterol
for membrane synthesis
and maintain cholesterol homeostasis?
So in these cells they
rely virtually completely on
the cholesterol biosynthetic pathway
and that is their source of cholesterol.
So the cell is happy
because the cell has its cholesterol
for its membrane synthesis,
but it's all at the expense
of an elevated
LDL in the bloodstream
which is the root of
this disease,
familial hypercholesterolemia
when the LDL builds up
and ultimately deposits in the skin
, in these xanthomas,
and in the artery wall
and produces atherosclerosis.
Brown: So over the next few years
we were able to define
in detail the pathway by which
LDL delivers
the cholesterols to cells
and it is shown on this slide.
After binding to the receptor in coated pits,
the LDL is internalized,
and it is delivered to endosomes,
and within endosomes
there are proton pumps
that acidify the interior
of the endosome.
That causes a conformational change
in the receptor
so that it releases the LDL particle.
The LDL is then carried further
into the lysosomes,
where it is totally degraded
and the cholesterol is liberated
for use to make new membranes.
LDL derived cholesterol
is also used for steroid hormones,
bile acids.
It is used to make
new lipoproteins, and
as Joe mentioned,
it exerts regulatory actions.
So the LDL derived cholesterol
is really important biologically.
After the LDL dissociates
from the receptor, the receptor
returns to the cell surface
in a recycling endosome.
And each of these,
each LDL receptor
makes one trip into and out of
the cell every 20 minutes.
And it makes
hundreds of trips during its
lifetime,  and each
time it carries an LDL particle
with 1500 molecules
of cholesterol ester.
We gave this process
its general name
which is receptor-mediated endocytosis
and after we had
described this system
for LDL, it turned out
that other scientists
found that other proteins
bound to their own receptors
on the surface
but they were taken in
into the cell in the same
way as LDL.
And the examples
include hormones such as insulin,
transport proteins such as transferrin,
which transports
iron and the protein
that transports vitamin B12.
So receptor mediated endocytosis
turned out to be
a general propery
of all cells, at least all
nucleated cells, and
it's interesting
that we had no idea
that we would stumble
into something that was so
general, because all we
wanted to do was
to figure out what was wrong
with these children with FH.
Brown: So, now this slide
shows what we looked like
when we started,
and what we look like now.
I think it is important
for any young people looking
at this video not to picture us
the way are now
as shown on the right.
But picture us as we were in 1972,
when I was 31 years old
and Joe was 32 years old.
That is when we
made these big discoveries
and the thrill of discovery
when you are young
and working hard
and something happens like that
FH experiment
that Joe described
the thrill of that is amazing.
And I want to say one other thing,
that it is a fantastic thing
to share that experience
with somebody else.
We have the longest
running partnership in
we think in the history of science
to be honest.
And I just have a
hard time understanding
why somebody
would want to do science
totally on their own without
somebody to share the adventure.
You wouldn't want to take a trip to Paris
by yourself, would you?
I mean you want somebody along
who can share the excitement
of that adventure
and that's what Joe and I have had.
So it's been
it's a fantastic thing
to have a partnership in science.